et on va plus loin avec zadimam
directeur du mensuel Afrique Magazine
qui titres ce mois-ci il y a le bonjour
Sur Côte d'Ivoire opération Grand Nord
ou la réponse d'un des autorités
ivoiriennes à la menace sécuritaire aux
frontières septentrionales on va en
parler dans un instant et on va voir je
l'espère la Une de d'Afrique magazine
qui devrait s'afficher d'un instant à
l'autre sur votre écran face à vous
Bruno Daru chroniqueur international ici
même à France 24 bonjour Bruno bonjour
Raphaël et voilà pour Afrique Magazine
l'Afrique alors également l'Afrique du
Sud le jeu en panne mais ce qui nous
intéresse nous à aujourd'hui on en
parlera tout à l'heure c'est la Côte
d'Ivoire avec cette opération Grand Nord
Emmanuel Macron lui est à Washington
jusqu'à vendredi le président français a
visité aujourd'hui la NASA accompagnée
des astronautes Thomas Pesquet de la
toute nouvelle lauréate Sophie anneau
accueilli sur place par Kamala Harris la
vice-présidente américaine qui a
souligné l'importance de l'entente avec
la France écoutée
nous sommes très fiers de travailler
avec la France pour cette mission en
matière d'exploration de l'espace les
États-Unis et la France sont partenaires
depuis plus de 60 ans au cours de cette
période nous avons fait de grands
progrès et à bien des égards nous
commençons un nouveau voyage ensemble
encore une fois je vous souhaite la
bienvenue monsieur le Président et je me
réjouis du travail que nous accomplirons
bienvenue
voilà la France des printemps en Allier
vital c'est un honneur particulier pour
la France et pour Emmanuel Macron Bruno
être reçu par Joe Biden pour cette
première visite d'État sous son mari
parce que c'était déjà le cas il faut le
rappeler de Donald Trump oui et
d'ailleurs côté statistique entre
guillemets Emmanuel Macron est le
premier président français a effectuer
deux visites d'État aux États-Unis il a
fait aussi un deuxième mandat donc
visite d'État effectivement c'est tout
le tralala Lafayette le dîner etc donc
on affiche
protocolaire
et ça permet d'afficher l'excellente
relation que les États-Unis
entretiennent avec cet allié les
Américains ont fait beaucoup juste avant
un des responsables du Département
d'État explique à la presse française à
Washington à quel point ils estimaient
qu'Emmanuel Macron était un leader
expérimenté sage qui jouait un véritable
rôle en Europe alors ils en font presque
un peu trop alors soit c'est pour
déplacer un peu ce qui s'est passé avec
la crise des sous-marins australiens
soit c'est pour essayer d'amadouer ce
Français qui va venir un peu on y
reviendra j'imagine il va venir un peu
râler sur le protectionnisme américain
donc on le traite très bien la façade
sera très belle ce sera de la
réconciliation mais derrière bien sûr il
y a quand même quelques dossiers qui
montrent que certes on est allié mais ça
n'empêche pas d'être compétiteur aussi
parce qu'on vient de loin il y a un an
les relations avaient très mal commencé
entre les deux hommes qu'on les
États-Unis avaient exclu de fait la
France d'une alliance et donc d'un
contrat de sous-marin avec l'Australie
on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui tout est
oublié ou pas je pense pas que tout est
oublié je pense que à ce niveau de
responsabilité on oublie rien on a des
fiches on a des notes on sait ce qui
s'est passé on a non non je pense que il
y a beaucoup de pragmatisme de part et
d'autre d'abord les Australiens ça leur
a pas porté bonheur parce que toute
façon ils ont toujours pas de sous-marin
et qui a l'air mal barré avec la
nouvelle commande mais pour en revenir
c'est ce que disait Bruno c'est que les
américains cherchent d'abord c'est quand
même un signe et c'est vrai qu'il y a
une histoire franco-américaine elle a
toujours été là on peut remonter à
l'indépendance au fait que voilà c'est
La Fayette il y a des liens très
puissants qui existent la Statue de la
Liberté la Louisiane enfin on pourrait
trouver toutes sortes de choses mais il
y a cette formation
il avait essayé de faire le coup de
charme avec Donald Trump on se rappelle
de la visite d'État à Washington sous
Donald Trump et c'était mal passé sorti
de l'accord de Paris sortie de l'accord
de Jessee away sur l'Iran donc on sait
que les Américains peuvent jouer leur
propre carte mais on fait un signe vers
Macron qui est considéré comme peut-être
le seul interlocuteur qui a un peu
d'expérience aujourd'hui en Europe
Scholtz et tout neuf les Anglais c'est
le bazar d'ailleurs je pense que pour
l'Angleterre c'est quand même un peu
surprenant de voir que leur alliés
historique privilégié privilégie la
France donc c'est intéressant aussi donc
voilà où on en est et puis il y a un
contentieux qui commence à s'installer
sur le coup de la guerre c'est pas la
guerre elle-même sur la guerre elle-même
on est absolument en raccord j'allais
dire entre disons entre une grande
partie de l'Europe et les États-Unis
mais le coût de cette guerre ce que ça
implique pour l'Europe en terme de coûts
énergétique de crise économique de
réindsement c'est pas la même chose
qu'aux États-Unis et il y a le fameux I
are une flèche réduction actes qui est
un immense package de 5 je sais plus 470
milliards 170 milliards de dollars qui
soi-disant va aider les États-Unis à
améliorer leur position climatique à
lutter contre l'affiation mais qui est
aussi un mécanisme formidable de
protectionniste puisque en gros ceux qui
vont bénéficier des budgets sont des
entreprises américaines il faut être
américain donc non seulement c'est
contre l'Europe et c'est un effet
d'aspirateur parce que suffit de se
délocaliser aux États-Unis de devenir
américain et de profiter donc il y a un
vrai il y a une vraie discussion qui
préfigure quand même un monde assez
brutal replié chacun sur son bloc il y a
un grand économiste qui parlait de la
guerre commerciale qui vient donc c'est
pas il y a pas que les flonflons il y a
pas que le dîner effectivement les
décorations il y a il y a un vrai enjeu
derrière il y aurait plus de ce que vous
dites Emmanuel Macron dénon c'est un
instant les subventions américaines
qu'il jugent dit-il super agressif à
l'égard des entreprises françaises donc
ça il le fait sur le seul américain
c'est dénonciation c'est quand même
assez fort on va écouter ce qu'on pense
de ce plan Thierry Breton et puis
évidemment vous réagirez juste après
dans un instant évidemment Bruno mais
d'abord donc le commissaire européen au
Marché intérieur
derrière ces mesures imposées par les
États-Unis il y a un risque plus
important selon moi d'un changement
complet des flux d'investissement nous
sommes ouverts au dialogue avec notre
partenaire américain par le biais de la
force d'int dédiée qui est une bonne
idée nous devons discuter
rendre à l'Amérique plus attractive à
travers ces entreprises protectionnistes
Joe Biden Bruno
oui d'une certaine manière mais
c'est assez c'est assez logique les
Américains ont toujours été comme ça
comme dirait de Gaulle les nations n'ont
pas d'amis le nom que des intérêts et de
ce point de vue là Joe Biden il faut
bien dire qu'il est quand même un peu
dans la lignée de Donald Trump alors
Donald Trump c'était America First Joe
Biden c'est America isback mais enfin
dans les faits entre les sous-marins
australiens et la ce plan il a il fait
un peu plus de mal à la France et à
l'Europe que ne l'a fait finalement
Donald Trump
donc bon Emmanuel Macron il va essayer
de faire ce qui peut il va sans doute
pas obtenir grand chose parce que c'est
pas au cours d'une visite d'État que
tout se règle
Anthony blinkel secrétaire d'État
américain accordé une interview
aujourd'hui à CNN et on lui a posé une
question sur la visite du président
français il a dit on comprend les
Américains sont pas complètement fermés
et on comprend on entend les inquiétudes
européennes on a mis sur place
d'ailleurs très vite une commission
mixte voilà qui essaye un peu de voir où
sont les problèmes mais en fait c'est
sans doute pas ça qui va faire changer
d'avis les Américains qui disent en gros
aux Européens bah écoutez vous avez qu'à
faire pareil c'est-à-dire vous avez qu'à
faire un bail européenne actes où vous
protégerez aussi vos entreprises
Emmanuel Macron il est il est assez
d'accord avec ça d'ailleurs il va
peut-être utiliser le fait d'être à
Washington pour envoyer un message à
Bruxelles pour pousser en ce sens les
Allemands sont un peu moins réticents
parce que eux ils n'apprécient pas non
plus une flexion réduction pour une
bonne raison c'est que la différence de
la France d'ailleurs eux ils vendent
vraiment beaucoup de voitures aux
États-Unis donc ça peut leur porter
préjudice mais seulement voilà l'Europe
comme d'habitude il y a beaucoup d'avis
divergents et beaucoup de pays qui ne
sont pas prêts à faire un espèce soit
alors Thierry Breton je crois d'ailleurs
à évoqué un grand fond souverain ou
alors un grand plan de relance comme on
a fait au moment du covid au niveau
européen et Emmanuel Macron lui il va
plutôt plaider pour ça et auprès de de
Joe Biden mais aussi indirectement
auprès de ses amis européens il aurait
tort de ne pas le faire et l'Europe avec
lui ce grand marché qu'on dépeint comme
ouvert à tous les bons au contraire il y
a un risque de repli protectrice on est
un peu en gros en 1929 aujourd'hui avec
des grandes économies qui cherchent
toutes les moyennes se barricadésiade
d'abord il y a pas que les États-Unis il
y a la Chine et et la discussion
européenne elle est là depuis très
longtemps c'est à dire que
elle est consubstantielle à l'idée du
marché unique et donc ce marché c'est
vrai qu'il est un petit peu ouvert et ce
qui fait aussi son attractivité donc le
débat sur bail européenne first c'est
aussi un débat financier c'est à dire
que quand les Américains mettent 400
milliards sur la table ou 375 ils
auraient bien voulu en mettre plus mais
leur divergence interne les ongles
mais là c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose là c'est de l'appui je sais le
plan européen si on décaisse de la
trésorerie pour que l'État là c'est
vraiment du sectoriel et de la
protection par exemple le cas précis des
Allemands pour vendre aujourd'hui une
BMW électrique aux États-Unis si le plan
s'applique entièrement c'est sa femme
voudrait avoir notre ami ça favorisera
notre ami Elon Musk et c'était cela et
donc il y a forcément un décalage et
donc je pense que la seule réponse à
cette tentative là c'est de montrer que
l'Europe et moi je suis assez d'accord
avec Gounod et capable de s'organiser de
la même manière c'est-à-dire de monter
un certain nombre de protection et de
protéger et de soutenir ces entreprises
mais nous notre fédéralisme il est pas
du tout le même que je les Etats-Unis
c'est-à-dire que pour que les Allemands
soient d'accords
qu'on s'y mette mais on en parle depuis
tellement longtemps c'est comme l'Europe
de la défense et puis franchement cette
histoire de l'Ukraine même si nous on ne
finance pas en premier lieu c'est les
Américains qui dépensent qui financent
qui arme qui envoie qui etc mais le coût
pour l'Europe et pas comparable au coût
pour les États-Unis les États-Unis sont
presque insularisés du coup de la guerre
à part ce que ça à part sur leur budget
et en même temps comme disait un
spécialiste il risque de détruire
l'armée russe pour le tiers ou le quart
de ce que serait coûté normalement
ces images d'ailleurs d'Emmanuel Macron
qui arrive c'est en ce moment même au
cimetière militaire Darlington puisqu'on
évoque justement à la situation de
l'Ukraine un mot peut être également sur
ce dossier ces deux alliés ne jouent pas
exactement la même partition là non plus
Bruno puisque depuis presque le début de
cette guerre que mène la Russie sur le
sol ukrainien Emmanuel Macron est
partisan de privilégier un canal de
négociation avec Vladimir Poutine et ce
qui est juste une différence de tonalité
où c'est plus profond avec Washington
oui enfin je pense que
au début effectivement les Américains
étaient un peu agacés de voir que
Emmanuel Macron continue à dialoguer au
téléphone avec Vladimir Poutine puisque
Joe Biden lui avait décidé de ne pas le
faire là les choses ont un peu évolué un
peu dans le sens du président français
puisque on commence quand même un petit
peu à réfléchir à l'après-guerre
potentiellement et on se dit que bon à
un moment il faudra bien négocier avec
quelqu'un et si vous Vladimir Poutine
est toujours là c'est bien avec lui
qu'il faudra parler donc du coup les
Américains sont un peu moins sévères
alors Emmanuel Macron dit bah vous voyez
j'avais raison j'ai bien fait de
continuer ce dialogue etc il y a un
autre sujet sur la guerre en Ukraine
c'est plutôt les Américains qui vont
faire peut-être un petit reproche à la
France parce que comme le disait Ziad
c'est eux qui massivement finance le
conflit en octobre enfin l'armement
occidentale à l'Ukraine et la France est
pas très bien classée donc je crois que
les Américains ont total ils ont ils ont
livré ou ils vont livrer 37 milliards de
dollars nous on en 220 millions donc Joe
Biden il va peut-être dire Emmanuel
Macron ce serait peut-être bien de faire
un petit effort supplémentaire en termes
de livraison d'armes vous avez même un
mot rapide on voit un intérêt côté
américain à la position française enfin
vis-à-vis de Poutine ou pour l'instant
c'est comme on a changé timing le fait
que quelqu'un qui est un canal c'est pas
forcément négatif surtout si c'est ce
quelqu'un là qui se crame et pas le
président des États-Unis donc ça me
semble être dans la logique des choses
et dans la logique européenne qui est
quand même encore une fois je rappelle
voisin pour l'éternité donc on n'a pas
tout à fait les mêmes approches que les
États-Unis allez on change de sujet il
avait causé la mort de 19 personnes 19
civils au Côte d'Ivoire l'attentat de
Grand-Bassam en 2016 dont le procès
s'est ouvert ce mercredi à Abidjan une
attaque revendiquée à l'époque par
alcaido maghrebislamique quatre accusés
comparés sur les 18 poursuivis à mon
Bruno à quel point la porosité des
frontières les tensions avec le Mali
aujourd'hui le travail de la justice
ivoirienne dans cette affaire oui parce
que en fait là ce qui se passe dans ce
procès qui est qui est important c'est
le premier procès pour terrorisme qui se
déroule en Côte d'Ivoire en fait les je
crois qu'il y a 18 quoi accusés au total
là il y en a que 4 qui sont présents
physiquement et c'est un peu des seconds
couteaux il y a un chauffeur
qui a conduit donc une des personnalités
qui a commandité l'attentat mais qui est
en fuite il y a une personne qui a
hébergé aussi des membres du commando il
y en a deux autres qui ont fait du
repérage voilà ce sont ces quatre
personnes qui se trouvent devant le
tribunal et
le cerveau de tout ça parce que c'était
admis à l'époque avait revendiqué
l'attentat bah lui tout simplement il
est au Mali en prison donc de fait il ne
pourra pas comparaître et ça dit
effectivement vu en plus le contexte de
tension depuis quelques mois entre la
Côte d'Ivoire et le Mali une forme
d'impuissance de la justice ivoirienne
qui ne parle pas finalement avoir dans
le tribunal les principaux accusés cette
attentat il a été suivi d'autres
attaques meurtrières en 2020-2020
spécifiquement contre les forces de
défense et de sécurité ivoirien où on
est aujourd'hui justement la situation
dans le nord de la Côte d'Ivoire bon il
y a une montée très très importante
j'allais dire en puissance avec une
stratégie de maillage des militaires des
forces spéciales une stratégie aussi de
dialogue avec les communautés parce
qu'en fait c'est les communautés qui qui
sont installées qui qui ont de
l'information qui sont souvent soumis à
des pressions de la part des djihadistes
donc il faut arriver à discuter et puis
il y a en Côte d'Ivoire
une approche j'allais dire un peu plus
globale puisque il y a eu il y a un plan
qui a été déclenché d'aide à la forme à
la formation qu'on a repéré le fait
enfin on a on a on a intégré le fait que
la jeunesse de ces régions qui sont des
régions défavorisées mais en Côte
d'Ivoire comme au Bénin comme au Togo
j'allais dire comme tous les pays de la
côte c'est Nord sahéliens qui sont
ouverts sur le désert qui sont moins qui
sont moins ancrés dans la modernisation
qui sont moins ancrées dans l'économie
en développement comme ceux qui
connaissent la Côte d'Ivoire peuvent
parler d'Abidjan mais vous pouvez
jusqu'à Bouaké et même jusqu'à Korhogo
en fait il y a un phénomène de de
d'économie active mais dès qu'on arrive
au-delà de ces de ces grandes villes on
est dans cette steppe ouverte avec des
véritables problématiques de contrôle
des frontières et et on a un journaliste
qui a suivi une des patrouilles bon les
il faut interdire les motos parce qu'on
sait pas mais derrière les motos il y a
pas forcément des djihadistes il y a
aussi des trafiquants de tout et
n'importe quoi de la drogue des
cigarettes de l'alcool des produits de
contrebande donc c'est cette zone
ouverte qui pose un problème qui
qui dépasse en fait la capacité chaque
État doit jouer son rôle mais s'il n'y a
pas une coordination entre ces états
très très précises pour surveiller ses
étendues c'est un premier problème et si
le reste du monde riche 800 je parle de
la France barkhane les États-Unis etc
n'accorde pas une attention stratégique
à cette zone elle est ingérable pour un
long pour un pour un pour un long temps
mais juste alors cette opération Grand
Nord décrit dans le titre c'est un titre
que nous on a mis mais c'est réellement
une préoccupation du pouvoir
en Côte d'Ivoire d'investir sur le plan
militaire et sur le plan social et le
plan de développemental mais le
rattrapage développemental ça va prendre
un certain les tensions avec le Mali qui
ont conduit d'ailleurs la Côte d'Ivoire
à retirer ses soldats du contingent des
des casques bleus c'est lié aussi à
l'affaire des soldats qui sont en prison
au Mali de l'année handicap justement la
capacité du du de la Côte d'Ivoire à
contré la menace terroriste dans cette
zone ça serait mieux comme je disais ce
serait mieux qu'il y ait une
collaboration entre les pays du Sahel et
les pays de la côte parce que ils sont
tous les deux menacés par par les
djihadistes c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui
c'est le Mali le Burkina
peut-être le Niger est menacé mais c'est
ce truc c'est c'est structuré les les il
y a une coopération plus active avec la
France mais c'est la même question aussi
avec la France et la France est le seul
pays
occidental qui est prêt encore à mettre
des moyens militaires de défense donc il
faut aussi que ce dialogue que ça soit
pays de la côte pays du Sahel et France
qui représente
l'Europe et le reste merci un peu
schématique mais on aura compris en tout
cas les enjeux merci également Bruno
Darro merci à vous il y a l'imam c'était
on va plus loin rendez-vous dans trois
minutes pour un nouveau journal d'Anne